hello and welcome to the cheeky science
show so i recently finished reading
atul gawande's book being immortal
illness medicine and what matters in the
end
so this is the fourth book written by
atul but he's not just a writer
but a surgeon at brigham and women's
hospital in boston and a professor at
harvard medical school
and so in this book [ __ ] provides an
honest portrayal of what it means to
grow older and to die
and how much control we have over
ourselves as we get older
he also delves into the viewpoint from a
doctor over not just prolonging
suffering or life
but to ensure quality of life he does
this by providing his own personal
experience
with stories from friends and patients
now at times this book made me feel
uncomfortable
but at others it was heartwarming and
reassuring so i'm very glad i've read it
so i thought i'd share five key
tk messages that i took from the book so
firstly
understanding aging
now this first part of the book is where
i felt most uncomfortable
as a follower of my channel you will
know that i covered the topic of aging a
lot
i would describe aging as the gradual
decline of cellular tissue
and organ failure that increases the
risk of developing diseases
including cancer neurodegeneration and
atherosclerosis
and can ultimately result in death but
in many ways this is a very scientific
description
of aging and lacks the emotion and
connection in the way that [ __ ]
describes it
you see atoll describes aging more
descriptively and more truthfully
which makes it more relatable which kind
of makes sense because we are all aging
and aging affects all of us
and so usual describes all aspects of
aging from the loss of the ability to
chew
to the loss of dexterity in the hands to
the increasing decline in lung capacity
and the slowing down of bowel movements
and even the shrinking of our brains
at the age of 30 the brain is a
three-pound organ that barely fits
inside the skull
by our 70s grey mata loss leaves almost
an inch of spare room
that's why elderly people like my
grandfather are so much more prone to
cerebral bleeding after a blow to the
head
the brain actually rattles around inside
and these are just a few of the
descriptions
now you probably are well aware that a
lot of research is being conducted to
try and extend health span
and to prevent aging the period of life
free from disease
but the reality is the number of people
with multiple morbidities is still
expected to increase in the coming years
and along with this lot of function
comes with it loss of independence
and with that as arsenal describes the
experience of advanced aging and death
has shifted to hospitals and nursing
homes and so with loss of independence
during aging comes dependence on others
and who will that be
and so this brings us on to the second
key point i want you to take from this
book
which is who will look after the elderly
now one answer are geriatricians
doctors who are specialized in the
health care of elderly people
however as artel describes the number of
certified geriatricians has fallen in
the u.s by 25
between 1996 and 2010. instead doctors
prefer to specialize in radiology and
plastic surgery
partly because of the low pay associated
with geriatricians
along with the fact that a lot of
doctors don't like looking after elderly
and here azel describes a conversation
with his friend felix silverstone
who was a geriatrician and he says that
with the elderly they don't just have a
chief complaint
they have 15 chief complaints how in the
world are you going to cope with all of
them
you're overwhelmed besides he's had a
number of these things for 50 years or
so
you're not going to cure something he's
had for 50 years he has high blood
pressure
he has diabetes he has arthritis there's
nothing glamorous about taking care of
any of these things
and so at all addresses this problem
well but that doesn't necessarily seem
to be any easy answers
instead he goes on to talk about
alternative options such as nursing
homes and assisted living
i say this now introduces us to dr bill
thomas and
the third taking that i want to talk
about which is regaining independence
and so bill thomas's experience began in
the early 1990s when he got a new job as
medical director of chase memorial
nursing home
in new york and he identifies that there
are three plagues of nursing home
existence
boredom loneliness and helplessness and
so
bill decided that he wanted to do
something about this
so he introduced dogs cats rabbits
hens plants and children all to the
nursing home
and they found in a study that over two
years the number of prescriptions
required per resident fell to half that
of the control nursing home
the total drug costs fell to just 38
of the comparison facility and deaths
fell by 15
so why did that happen well thomas said
i believe the difference in death rates
can be traced to the fundamental human
need for a reason to live
and goes along with thomas's belief that
a good life was one of maximum
independence
which is exactly what his changes were
trying to achieve in place of boredom
they offer spontaneity
in place of loneliness they offer
companionship and in place of
helplessness they offer a chance to take
care of another being
and all of this for thomas was just the
starting point for a larger program
named eden alternative which over the
last
20 or so years has de-institutionalized
nursing homes
and also resulted in the so-called
greenhouse project
and greenhouses not like the grey of
plants
in this respect are small and communal
with a physical environment made to
preserve quality of life
self-sufficiency privacy and dignity and
would host no more than 12 residents
each and if you're like me and like ted
talks then there's
a ted talk given by dr phil thomas on
youtube that i'll link here for you to
check out
and so shifting slightly into the fourth
take home from this book
it focuses more about alleviating
suffering for patients
and the importance of end-of-life
discussions with the doctor and the
important
roles that a doctor plays in this
discussion and so obviously atl
is a doctor whereas i'm not but even
reading this i think it's important to
understand
the framework in which doctors address
questions to patients
as it will likely affect all of us at
some point if not already
and so atoll references a 1992 paper
that he was assigned to read during
medical school
that was written by two medical
ethicists ezekiel and linda emmanuel
and this paper was all about the
different kinds of relationships that
uttle as a budding new clinician
might have with patients and ask the
question
what should the ideal physician-patient
relationship be
and so in this book atoll describes
three of these relationships
the first one is paternalistic and this
is the doctor that
we read about from the 50s the
all-knowing god-like figure that tells
the patients what they should do
and does not discuss options that the
doctor does not think are optimal
and although often denounced it remains
a common mode especially with vulnerable
patients
the frail the poor the elderly and
anyone who tends to do what they're told
the second type of relationship that
utel mentions
is the informative doctor and in many
ways
this is the complete opposite of the
paternalistic relationship
here the doctor informs the patient of
the facts and figures
needed to figure out the best option and
then lets the patient make the decision
and so as util says in truth neither
type is quite what people desire
we want information and control but we
also want guidance
and so the emanuels in this paper
describe a third type of doctor-patient
relationship
which they called interpretive which is
why the doctor's role is to help
patients determine what they want
interpretive doctors ask what is most
important to you
what are your worries then when they
know your answers
they will tell you about the different
options and which one would most help
you achieve your priorities
and so atl emphasizes in this book the
importance of asking patients what
matters most to them
and to quotes from the book if
end-of-life discussions were an
experimental drug
the fda would approve it i said the last
take-home that i want to mention
is that we are all elders in the making
and so throughout this book
atoll describes his own personal
experience with his relationship with
his father
he was suffering with spinal cord tumor
and so here ato had to use the lesson
that he'd learnt
to help his father and whilst they made
some good decisions
and also some potential mistakes by
asking his father
what were his priorities by the end of
the chapter
his father is in hospice and living a
surprisingly full life however sadly
asshole's father's life did come to an
end
but also describes that we were lucky to
get to hear him tell
us his wishes and say his goodbyes and
having a chance to do so he let us know
he was at peace
that let us be at peace too and so all
in all being immortal is about the
struggle to cope with the constraints of
our biology
and i feel lucky that i've not really
had to deal firsthand
with some of the issues discussed in
this book but i feel like it has better
prepared me for when those times will
inevitably
come and whilst this book probably will
resonate a lot with doctors
who deal with patients daily and may
make them think differently about the
questions they ask their patients and
the decisions they make
i feel this book will ultimately
resonate with everyone since
we are all elders in the making and so i
know that this is a bit different to my
usual videos but i finished reading the
book and felt like i wanted to talk
about it
and so i know that some of you probably
have your own viewpoints and opinions as
well and i'll be interested to hear them
i think that it's something we need to
talk about more often and shouldn't be
afraid to talk about it
since inevitably the demographics are
changing and
it will affect our lives more and more
in the future and so with that
i want to give a thank out to my patreon
supporters who i'm incredibly grateful
for
and i hope you've learned something in
this video and thanks for listening